we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P listen this this really
bums me out
I have been accurately telling you fine
folks in my audience
you can subscribe for free to my YouTube
channel it's just it's YouTube okay you
just subscribe that just means you get
our videos it's free it's completely
free you can subscribe free to our
podcast it's on iTunes Spotify Pandora
Stitcher it's everywhere it's free okay
and
every once in a while I get a voicemail
like this and it really bums me out
hello I've tried going to your site you
say on T on your
uh podcast that I can subscribe for free
and there's nowhere to subscribe for
free what kind of scam are you pulling
yeah there is no scam
95 of the content we do
on every platform is free to everyone we
have a YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show
it's YouTube guys it's free you can
subscribe free
we have a podcast an hour every single
weekday
it's free you go to our website you go
to iTunes you go whatever is your
favorite podcasting app it's free
what we charge for
our website memberships which come with
a commercial free version of the show
they come with access to the bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money yeah everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad and they
come with other perks okay but it's free
to subscribe on YouTube it's free to
subscribe to the podcast there's no scam
here there's no scam here let's all
relax we have a great bonus show for you
today Joe Biden is going after so-called
junk fees I will tell you what these are
Texas is going permitless on guns
that'll go well right and three men have
been convicted on all counts for the
plot to kidnap
Michigan Democratic governor Gretchen
Whitmer remember that story they have
all been convicted on all counts all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up with peace and love at
joinpakman.com this isn't free okay this
part's not free you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get a discount but
if you want to request a free membership
we have some to give away you can
request a free membership at
davidpackman.com
slash free membership we'll see you on
the bonus show